the Western Conference trophy is named
after one of the greatest players of all
time the big Oscar Robertson here to
accept the Oscar Robertson western
conference champions trophy on behalf of
the Denver Nuggets head coach Michael
Malone
[Applause]
coach you said before this game that
Closeouts are the hardest what was the
key to getting this done tonight well
first off you have to give a lot of
credit and respect to the Lakers Darvin
ham LeBron James Anthony Davis they gave
us a hell of a challenge today but the
guys behind me they believe since
training camp they believe coming into
tonight we have a special group and if
you've heard all series long Lisa we're
not satisfied we got four more to go but
love this group let's go nugget Nation
coach you've also said all series long
that you didn't look at making history
for this team as a burden or a weight
but but an opportunity what's been the
most satisfying part about this journey
I think for me the most satisfying part
about the journey is who I'm on the
journey with I have a tremendous
coaching staff I have a tremendous front
office great ownership and the 17
players behind me who came to work every
day
check their Eagles at the door for
something much bigger than themselves we
have great players we have tremendous
depth we have a lot of character on this
team and I love each and every one of
our players thank you coach thank you
Lisa
the Western Conference Finals Most
Valuable Player trophy is aptly named
after one of the greatest guards in NBA
history Urban Magic Johnson the 2023
Irvin Magic Johnson Western Conference
Finals Most Valuable Player award goes
to Nicola jokic
[Music]
[Applause]
Nicola you've said that you could care
less about what anybody else says about
this team about getting any attention I
think this trophy speaks for itself what
does it symbolize for you
because for me to be honest nothing uh
so this trough is supposed to go to my
teammates and coaches uh they put me in
the situation
I'm just I'm just a first among the
equals and uh I'm just happy that we are
collectively getting wins and getting to
make something the Denver Nuggets are
headed to the NBA finals for the first
time in the franchise's history what
would you like to say to your fans back
home in the city of Denver I mean uh
probably just to say a lot to my parents
my bad I mean it's it's a collective
effort for real it's from from the spark
you know who is our treatment manager to
a family cranky I think the it's a one
Collective effort that we are growing as
a as a team as a franchise I think it's
really nice to be a nugget fan thank you
Nicole and congratulations where's Jamal
[Applause]
and Jamal a year ago you were still
rehabbing your way back from an ACL tear
and now here you are headed to the
finals just
what does that mean to you
I'm just glad I put the work in uh
during the rehab so I can reflect on
that moment
um not regret anything during the rehab
so let's come out here be here with my
guys everybody support you through the
way
so to make it this far with everybody
just means a lot but I know that the job
is not done yet for sure what have you
Nicola what have you guys all said to
each other about what it's going to take
to get you to where you ultimately want
to be it's going to take us to be
together I think that's the main thing
uh we can do anything together as soon
as we start to separate that's when we
struggle
so once we do that through the ups and
downs we'll be fine thanks Jamal thank
you congratulations once again
to the 2023 Western Conference Champion
Denver Nuggets and MVP Nicola jokic
Mike Breen back to you
all right Lisa biggest night in
franchise history
greatest victory in franchise history
there might be a few more of those
coming up as they get ready for their
first NBA finals